Kevin Hart breaks his silence after his
crash as the newly released CHP report
reveals what caused the horrific
accident the roof and the cars pretty
photo the startling 35 page report
includes 32 photos of Kevin's mangled
1970 Plymouth Barracuda you can see the
crushed roof and shattered windshield
according to the investigation Kevin's
friend Jared Stanton black was driving
when his quote reckless sudden and rapid
acceleration forced him to lose control
of the vehicle Jarrett's fiance Rebecca
Brock Sturman was next to him Kevin was
in the back which had been quote
converted into a storage area and no
longer actually had seats the report
says that black was not under the
influence of drugs or alcohol it also
states that no one was wearing their
seatbelts properly and it also mentions
that after the crash Kevin quote exited
the vehicle and left the scene of the
collision after the report revealed
Kevin's friend caused the crash the
comedian released a brief statement
through his attorney quote I have
nothing but love for Jared and wish him
and Rebecca a speedy recovery as for
Kevin's recovery a source tells et he is
quote not planning to go back to work
full-time until the first of the year
we're told Kevin fractured his spine in
three places our source says the 40 year
old was hospitalized for ten days after
the crash and then was transferred to a
rehabilitation facility he recently
returned home where he continues his
physical therapy also this week Kevin
put in two hours of work for promos for
the upcoming Jumanji sequel we talked to
his co-star Aquafina today Kevin's great
man yeah we just saw me the other day
and he's his own funny song
[Music]
[Applause]